the human salivary glands contain an
enzyme called PTY l.p tya Li and
Thailand that is an enzyme that is for
the digestion of carbohydrate
carbohydrate is not protein we don't
have fangs we have four of 32 poorly
developed canine teeth for tearing meat
and I can keep going on for the list of
things why the human body is designed to
be mostly vegetarian vegan is a hundred
percent if you do the math on four out
of 32 that's eighty seven and a half
percent so instead of a hundred percent
being vegan is a hundred percent so I
think that our diet is supposed to be
organic unprocessed whole foods at the
eighty seven and a half percent level
with the other twelve and a half percent
being meat or and that should be
free-range meat pasture fed meat or wild
fish or cage free eggs as examples of
the type of animal protein that we can
have so it's that translates if you do
the math to a palm-sized serving of
animal protein two to three times a week
actually it's two and a half times a
week so we could have a poem site your
poem for you my poem for me Wilt
Chamberlain's poem for him Kareem
abdul-jabbar's poem for him we could
have palm size servings two to three
times per week and we will then be
fitting with our natural biologic design
and once again that's what real
preventive medicine is it is being in
tune with what is our natural biologic
design and our biologic design calls for
us to be lean trim low percent body fat
active+ non-smoking highly organic
unprocessed whole foods diet and so on
so you I think that we are designed to
be mostly vegetarian
and do it or don't do it by invitation
this is not a command this is what your
biology is fish are supposed to breathe
water birds are supposed to fly I don't
advise the human race to go to a cliff
and jump off because they want to be
like a bird or stay underwater for two
hours because they want to be like a
fish unless obviously they bring their
above water air with them and so what
I'm saying to you is that there is a
natural human design and I've already
given that several times breathe right
drink right eat right exercise right
think right and then diseases don't
happen we are in an American culture we
do so many or Western culture we do so
many things wrong that it turns out that
some of the good that comes from
drinking alcohol counterbalances most of
the bads that we're doing if we had an
organic unprocessed Whole Foods diet at
the eighty seven and a half percent
level we wouldn't need the benefits of
that alcohol bottom line is I think safe
amount of alcohol in order to avoid
cancer of the esophagus and liver
disease and heart disease and brain
disease and home abuse and trauma and
auto accidents is right at four drinks a
week or less and I'm not arguing I'm
just telling you my best guess on what
the human body the natural human design
is to be able to tolerate alcohol
alcohol is toxic at any level to heart
muscle liver tissue and brain tissue in
any dose you put any dose of alcohol
into a cell culture of those cells and
they start leaking enzymes and that's a
sign of those cells being intoxicated